were there any stories or anything that
kind of happened within the free agency
that are kind of Untold I was a Sunday
night football game in Tampa watching
the Bucks play the Saints and also my
agent calls me it's like 10 o'clock and
he's like hey we got to get you on a
flight out to these winter meetings I'm
like what are you talking about I got a
flight in two days with my wife to go
out to Hawaii we're going out there for
a little vacation what do you mean I've
got to go to San Diego he's like now we
got to get you here like ASAP like in
the morning stuff buzzing teams are
calling it was just in and out like a
little over Mission you know they should
pop in there pop out and people don't
see that type of stuff man yeah